a lot of fans are very excited about
this Hamilton mixtape yes where you're
getting artists to interpret the
soundtrack from Hamilton which track are
you kind of the most excited about can
you say yeah I mean it's impossible to
pick literally every single one of these
artists was you know an inspiration for
the mixtape or someone I'm in love with
their music I do have to say when
Ashanti and Ja Rule's sing helpless it
will give you all the feels as the
children of the internet say when I was
writing that song I was picturing it as
an Asante ja Rule like we're actually
thinking about them yeah yeah I was like
Eliza's Ashanti Hamilton's ja Rule two
verses two choruses or little ja Rule
and they came to the show together like
we asked them to come to the show and
they came like as dates like just like
in the video and that night when I was
doing that rap I just did the whole
thing in my jaw voice you really did I
was like editing from on state ja Rule
know that you were doing it as him he
must have he said he said I'll turn to
my wife and said yo he's channeling it
which is the greatest compliment long as
I'm alive Eliza
you